oh that's good singing that'll distract
him
twin brothers who must be forced to
fight father never loved you as much he
loved me twice as much as he ever loved
you shut up you know our mother or the
complicated man how you say the words do
it in God I just watch what are try to
go through this Lazo him rock I can't
wait to get back home to my mom and dad
they love me so much
oh oh okay nice ballerina move I want to
see that in slow motion and
danten danten
that's right you get out of here this is
my Beach what do you think no no love
your pastors do it for me
what's hot you need me to go into the
woods Thank You lightning God
the birds murder matharis well that
looked impressive right off the bat but
then it turned into something a little
bit silly you all right buddy needs a
mouth and need some water
you good so apparently every time I get
some warmer air here that's right you
follow you leave them alone you leave
Jerry alone what did he ever do to you I
think of crying Jesus she's like wasted
and lady minutes we've been like jumping
on this finally she was like all right
if you jump on me 13 everybody ready
yeah
3 2 1 go are you doing clicking and
pressing up at the same time I'll just
have the chairs obviously telling me
that I am indeed in the mood to read not
in the mood to be to blow those candles
anymore yeah
he's like Mary hell yeah indeed come
here old lady that you're about to punch
into oblivion thanks for watching all of
the videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more of a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye